of the fortunate things about being a
writer particularly being a writer for
The Spectator is that
you can say what you think without
repercussion and increasingly in our
society that isn't the case we see
extraordinary situations people losing
their jobs for stating very basic truths
that everyone agreed until 48 hours ago
um my view is that writers have a
disproportionate duty to tell the truths
that a lot of other people are
increasingly unable to say
and the analogy I use an analogy of a
device I discovered the British army
uses it's called great Viper and you
pull it to the edge of a Minefield and
then you fire this huge missile it goes
over Minefield with this long explosive
tale and as it lands and it detonates in
one go
the analogy came to mind because this
can't clear all the minds but it can
make it safer for people to cross the
field